in general as an ally of Britain
especially in NATO and the partner in
the European Union a key but Britain for
us is a key part in the European Union
so we will do our best to help Britain
because we want the United Kingdom to
remain in the European Union to be an
active member shaping the rules
regulations in the you of course we have
we have some red lines we have the
national interest of Poland so we will
be discussing the details once they are
presented by the prime minister but we
are ready to help as much as you can the
biggest problem is probably going to be
this question of freedom of movement yes
do you think there's any way that
Britain could stop the freedom of
movement people coming to this country
from within the EU while remaining a
member we are open to negotiate anything
unless it's non-discriminatory and it's
done in accordance with the EU law free
movement of people who is one of the
four fundamental freedoms of the
European Union so we would we would be
against any kind of opt outs or
selective treatment of this freedom
cherry-picking things of this kind but
we would support fighting abuse of the
system we are open to talk about
anything that would be
non-discriminatory as I have said so
because it is important to the Polish
economy at the moment that Polish people
can come here and work of course many of
them go home afterwards it is important
for the economy but it's more than this
it's important for the European
integration and solidarity this is one
of basic freedoms of the European Union
and and of course many Britons enjoy
this living abroad in many European
countries so this is this is not just a
special trip not so many in Poland know
but but many in Portugal in Spain in
other places so so this is the this free
movement of people which shows that we
are on the same continent it shows our
solidarity and does that include being
able to send a worker here poets working
here being able to send benefits back to
their family who are not resident here
this is one of the things that perhaps
differs us because we think that people
from Poland who work here in the United
Kingdom are no different from British
citizens working here because we live
here we pay taxes here we rent
apartments here we use restaurants here
we contributed the prosperity of this
country so and paying the paying
benefits to children in Poland would be
like subsidizing British taxpayers more
or less what if we if it didn't happen
you mean yes there is there is no
difference between a Polish worker here
working legally here and a British work
or a French worker or Spanish or
Bulgarian we're ready I mean you
understand from the point of view a lot
of British people they might see well
we're paying a lot of money in Poland
pones not paying a lot of money in our
direction I don't know if this is this
is true because the contribution of the
migrants here and a second to none it's
in billions of pounds the contribution
to the British budget so we are
contributing a plus we we are also
contributing in the European Union for
example the rebate of the United Kingdom
so so it's not it's not like this they
they work here and they pay taxes here
and they continue to the prosperity of
Britain we would like to have them in
problem especially young people because
they would work for our pensions and
they would contribute a lot to our
prosperity in Poland and at the moment
the different in way difference in wages
is is such that they they would rather
work here now your capital Warsaw was
one of the first that David Cameron
visited on his tour to build up support
you were there did you get the
impression that David Cameron really
really does want to keep britain within
the European Union yes this is my
impression man the Prime Minister
presented areas of concern and that
where he would like to see reforming the
European Union and with a lot of things
we can we can agree and we can subscribe
to his vision we should reduce the red
tape we should work for a more
competitive Europe create more jobs etc
so we should ensure the quality of
treatment between euro countries and non
Europe countries Poland is not in the
eurozone just like the UK so we can
subscribe to many of the postulates
presented by the Prime Minister I
I think the Prime Minister believes in
Europe because he knows how much the UK
gets from the membership and but also
Europe gets a lot from the membership of
the UK you know Britain very well what
is it matters late seventies do you
think we are a Euroskeptic anti-european
country as a whole I don't know it's
very difficult to say it's a lot is
about perceptions about feelings the
role of the media here is and it's very
specific i would say in this no i think
i think a lot of people can see the
benefits of membership if you go to the
City of London if you if you talk to to
to to people there they appreciate how
important the membership of the U is a
lot of people have misconceptions
perhaps and we should clarify those
misconceptions and and we should work
for more integration of migrants get to
know each other better fight ignorance
and show the positive contributions of
immigrants and then perhaps also make a
difference between third countries in
the European Union this is not really
migration this is free movement of
people as I say free circulation of
brains in the European Union and what do
you say as you as you go around Britain
when people say to you were why should
we bother why should we stay in the
European Union what's your answer to
that well and we are not interfering in
the internal affairs of the UK so I'm
trying to present the national interest
of Poland in this respect not so much
give your eyes people much device must
say what's the point this is this is
what I always say that ivory and I I try
to to say a few words about the history
of the European Union how it started
after the Second World War and how how
good it was for the for Europe in
general preventing us from fighting wars
and and also contributing to the
prosperity of the continent and some
people say yes it's very different now
because we started with six founding
members now we have a lot of members of
the you
but look it's also about it's it's also
about trade is also about investments
also about freedom it's about a lot of
things that are taken for granted and
this is a pity because a lot of people
think this is taken for granted it will
be forever and it's not the case i mean
it's it's we should appreciate the
benefits of the membership not just the
new so-called new countries we don't
like the term but also but also the
founding members of the communities and
how do you think referendums going to go
in this country I hope Britain is going
to remain in the United in the in Europe
because this is this is important to all
of us but it will be a Democratic
decision of the British population I
master thank you thank you